on july 24 2019 elon musk announced a
big change to the tesla management team
important update jv stravel co-founder
and chief technology officer will be
transitioning to a senior advisor from
the cto role this was a pretty dramatic
moment after all jb had worked alongside
elon for 15 years and helped transform
tesla from a tiny startup into a massive
public company so why would jb call it
quits at tesla after so many great years
working with elon
jb had realized something really
important and he had to act immediately
he had seen electric vehicles become a
reality firsthand and could tell that
the industry was going to be massive
these new evs would help curb carbon
emissions but they created a new problem
e-waste the staggering amount of the
world's e-waste is ending up being burnt
in open dumps in impoverished ghana
recycling old lithium-ion batteries is
incredibly difficult and without a solid
program to deal with them e-waste will
just start piling up this wasn't just an
opportunity to help keep the environment
clean though it could also be a huge
business so jb left tesla to start a new
company called redwood materials this
story gets less attention than your
average elon musk tweet but it's
incredibly important so let's dive into
the used battery problem and how jb is
planning to solve it
lithium nickel cobalt and graphite are
all key components in lithium-ion
batteries but mining them can be
incredibly damaging to the environment
extracting just one ton of lithium from
the andes mountains requires 500 000
gallons of water mining nickel in russia
has lowered the life expectancy of the
local residents by 10 years and 60 of
the global cobalt supply comes from the
democratic republic of congo where
manual laborers work in dangerous mines
without safety equipment it's all
incredibly difficult so it's absolutely
critical that when we extract a
particular resource from the earth we
don't let it go to waste pollution is a
huge issue and it doesn't end with
mining after raw materials are extracted
from the earth they need to travel to a
refinery which is often in another
country and once they actually are
refined transforming these resources
into something that can actually be used
in a battery requires another trip
across the globe to a different factory
the entire process from mining to final
battery pack assembly can often incur
tons of carbon emissions since the
supply chain spans the entire world
these batteries also don't last forever
even though many ev batteries can now
last for hundreds of thousands of miles
before failing we will still need to
recycle millions of battery packs in a
few decades we simply don't have enough
recycling capacity to handle the wave of
dead lithium-ion batteries that is
coming once today's ev owners start
scrapping their cars currently only five
percent of all lithium-ion batteries
wind up getting recycled fortunately jb
strabal saw this problem coming and is
working on a solution but before looking
at his plan for redwood materials and a
full sustainable battery we have to
examine what makes him uniquely
qualified to tackle these challenges
jb's interest in electric vehicles
developed back in the 1980s well before
most people even knew that evs were a
real possibility at age 13 he rebuilt an
old electric golf cart which taught him
how batteries and electric motors worked
it was a kind of a souped-up electric
golf cart that was a whole lot of fun
did it work it worked well it was maybe
a little too dangerous many successful
entrepreneurs have stories like this
when elon musk was 12 years old he
programmed a video game and sold it to a
magazine for 500 bucks and bill gates
landed a contract to build software for
a water utility when he was just a
teenager working on a hobby project with
a tangible outcome is a great way to
learn important skills the earlier you
start building the more time you'll have
to let these skills compound on one
another jb's builder mindset led him to
stanford in 1992 he was already
interested in electric vehicles but
there weren't really any degrees that
fit his interests so he wound up
building his own curriculum he studied
physics and chemistry to get a handle on
how the batteries would work in an
electric vehicle and then he took
courses in computer science to
understand how to control the electric
motors i actually defined my own major
and ended up
defining a major called energy systems
engineering are you the only person in
the history of the world has done it
well i think at this point you know they
actually have a whole track you know
focused on energy i'm pretty jealous you
know when i was there there wasn't too
much to do he wasn't only focused on
class though while working on his
bachelor's degree jb also worked at
rosen motors a company designing a new
hybrid powertrain the system was ahead
of its time but the big car companies
weren't interested in rethinking their
car designs so rosen had to shut down in
1997. jb graduated from stanford in the
year 2000 but he stuck around on campus
for a few extra years he'd started
building electric race cars with some
other stanford friends and really
enjoyed the process they would buy a
normal car with an internal combustion
engine and then install an electric
powertrain and a battery pack each
iteration would show small improvements
and more importantly teach them a ton a
few years into building these vehicles
jb set a new world record using a
converted electric porsche 944 a few
years later jb moved to los angeles to
work for ac propulsion the business was
small but they were one of the few
companies working on custom-built
electric cars so it was a great fit they
had designed a two-seat electric sports
car called the t-0 and this thing was
fast it could do 0 to 60 in just 4.9
seconds which is pretty slow by modern
tesla standards but back then it was
fast enough to turn heads
there was a problem though it had an
extremely limited range the original
version of the t0 used a lead acid
battery pack and could only do around
100 miles of driving on a single charge
fortunately battery technology was
improving rapidly at the turn of the
millennium and the latest generation of
lithium-ion batteries had much higher
storage capacities when the ac
propulsion team changed from lead acid
to lithium-ion in 2003 their car's range
increased to 300 miles and the 0-60 time
actually went down the car could now hit
60 miles per hour in just 3.6 seconds
and it was actually because of a
technology shift that they gave us a toe
hold to start the company and it was a
shift around the battery technology from
lead acid to lithium ion that
fundamentally changed the type of
product that you could build with an
electric car jb had been building the
perfect set of skills for years so when
he sat down for lunch with elon in 2003
it was clearly the beginning of a great
partnership elon was 31 years old back
then and he just made 165 million
dollars from paypal so he was ready to
start writing some big checks in the
green energy space jb initially pitched
elon a plan to build a hydrogen-powered
aircraft but elon wasn't a fan of the
idea it was a rocky start to the
relationship but jb saved the
conversation by telling elon about the
t0 elon already had a deep fascination
with electric vehicles and instantly
wanted to go for a ride even though ac
propulsion had done some great
engineering work the business plan
wasn't as solid as it could have been
the t0 was just a proof of concept and
it didn't even have doors or windows it
clearly wasn't street legal and even
worse it cost 220 000 to produce a
single vehicle so mass production was
still a long way away elon and jb
believed in the potential of the t0 but
they just couldn't convince ac
propulsion to start scaling
manufacturing and this is why jb and
elon wound up working on tesla and not
ac propulsion it's all just a very
interesting case of serendipity if if we
hadn't had lunch in 2003 tesla wouldn't
wouldn't exist basically yeah it's been
a quite an adventure of 16 years jb
officially joined tesla in 2004 as chief
technology officer his salary was 95 000
but obviously the stock options he
received wound up making that look like
pennies every massively successful
startup has plenty of stories like this
and it's a big reason why so many smart
people take pay cuts and risk everything
to work on bold new ideas jb wound up
getting a huge payday from tesla but
this wasn't just luck without jb who
knows what would have happened to tesla
and jb didn't join tesla with financial
gain in mind just like elon he had a
great mission jb was already thinking
about climate change in the early 2000s
and knew that electric cars could help
significantly reduce emissions on top of
that jb was a passionate engineer and
joining tesla would allow him to work on
the hardest engineering problems in the
world one of the first problems that
tesla ran into when building the
original roadster was finding a good
supplier for batteries back in the mid
2000s most lithium-ion battery
manufacturers focused on consumer
electronics like ipods and laptops they
simply didn't have the experience or
scale to support the demands of ev
battery packs it took tesla years before
they were able to ink a deal with
panasonic to reliably produce
high-quality batteries lithium-ion as a
technology class was invented for
consumer electronics it was not invented
for transportation today in the last
maybe one or two years have we seen that
start to shift where the manufacturing
methods the scale of operations even the
scale of r d is starting to increase to
the automotive level and to the energy
storage level for the grid supply chain
issues weren't the only problem for
tesla in the early days though the
roadster also faced numerous design
challenges tesla planned to use the
lotus elise chassis to simplify the
production process but it actually wound
up making things more complicated in
order to fit the massive battery pack
inside of the vehicle the tesla
engineers had to rebuild a large part of
the original chassis this was just the
beginning of the tesla roadster's
problems though in 2007 an internal
audit showed that tesla had been too
optimistic about how much it would cost
to build the roadster instead of the
seventy thousand dollars they had
budgeted for a single car would cost
closer to a hundred and forty thousand
dollars the plan was to sell each
roadster for a hundred and nine thousand
dollars so tesla would lose money on
every car that they sold the financial
system was in turmoil at the time so the
team had to figure out a solution
quickly fortunately jb stepped up and
worked with his engineering team to
reduce the production cost to 80
thousand dollars it wasn't a huge profit
margin but it was enough to demonstrate
the financial viability of the business
and get tesla through the ipo process in
2010.
the roadster project was easy compared
to what was coming next though everyone
who bought a roadster was an early
adopter and they knew full well that
there might be issues for tesla's first
mass market car the model s the stakes
would be much higher jb led the team
through a massive transformation as
tesla acquired a 42 million
manufacturing plant in fremont set up a
supercharger network and then started
working on the gigafactory pretty much
you know moved to nevada in those days
and camped out at the gigafactory and
did everything i possibly could do to
make batteries possible and battery
packs and motors and everything else it
was pretty crazy the gigafactory allowed
tesla to bring battery cell production
from japan to the united states and
finally guaranteed that they would have
enough batteries to build new cars it's
impressive to see how successful this
project has been the factory now
produces 37 gigawatt hours worth of
batteries every year enough to make it
the biggest battery factory in the
entire world but as jb was working on
building the gigafactory he realized
that solving the battery production
problem would just create a new problem
battery recycling nearly 300 000
electric vehicles were sold in the
united states last year and this number
is projected to grow to nearly 7 million
per year by 2025 factory in
international markets and you quickly
get to a point where tens of millions of
batteries will need to be decommissioned
every single year this can feel far away
as you're driving around on a day-to-day
basis since most of the cars you see on
the road still use gasoline but jb has
seen exponential growth firsthand at
tesla and he understands that there's
really no time to waste if we don't
build enough battery recycling factories
in time we're going to be in a very
tough situation jb actually believes
that the problem is so big we need not
one but four different companies working
on solutions
now obviously jb can't build all four
companies but he can certainly set an
example in this new industry this is why
jb resigned from tesla in 2019 to found
redwood materials the goal of the
company is to build what's called a
closed-loop battery manufacturing
ecosystem that's industry jargon for
basically just recycling old batteries
into new ones and even though it sounds
pretty simple the technology required is
extremely complex and the business is
very capital intensive investors clearly
believe in the opportunity here though
this past summer jb raised 700 million
dollars at a 3.7 billion valuation from
goldman sachs bill gates and jeff bezos
not exactly a group of nobodies and jb
has already started putting this money
to work his first factory is up and
running in nevada and can process 60
tons of batteries every single day that
works out to the equivalent of just
under 50 000 electric vehicle batteries
per year which is still a long way from
the tens of millions of batteries we are
expecting in the future but it's a
promising start even though redwood is
still a young company jb and his team
have already captured 50 of the
lithium-ion battery recycling market and
could do 90 million in revenue this year
jb's experience in the industry is
clearly paying off already he's been
able to strike a deal with ford to
recycle their old battery packs and
partnered with an electric bus company
named proterra to manufacture new
batteries this two-sided closed-loop
approach gives jb lots of flexibility
when it comes to partnering with
existing companies working on electric
vehicles redwood can help recycle old
batteries which many companies don't
have a plan for yet or they can help
make new batteries with the recycled
materials and even a company like tesla
can partner with redwood even though
tesla's operation is pretty efficient a
small portion of the materials they use
to make batteries at the nevada
gigafactory end up going to waste
redwood is able to recycle this waste
and extract valuable materials to feed
back into the gigafactory manufacturing
process it's all about squeezing every
possible efficiency out of supply chains
and when you're dealing with a massive
industry that has big implications jb
doesn't want to stop with just battery
recycling though there's another part of
the ev battery supply chain under
pressure right now car companies and
battery manufacturers are constantly
announcing massive plans to build out
battery cell production capability but
making the batteries is just one part of
the puzzle the components that go into
the cells cathodes anodes electrolytes
and separators also need to come from
somewhere unlike asia which has a
historically strong battery supply chain
the us lacks domestic manufacturing
capability in this area if we don't
figure out how to make enough of these
precursor materials we could be faced
with something similar to the chip
shortage where a lack of upstream
components slows everything else down
luckily jb is already positioning
redwood to produce critical parts a
great example of this is his plan for a
copper foil manufacturing plant he
recently bought a hundred acres of land
in nevada to build a factory explicitly
for this purpose now a factory that only
produces rolls of copper might sound
boring but this foil is actually really
important because it's a key component
needed to make the anode for the battery
you know copper can be even more silly
you know north america you know is a big
scrap market for copper wire plumbing
you know all these things we're a big
generator of copper waste yet we don't
have much copper manufacturing so we
actually export copper scrap back to
china you know where it gets made into
the same anode copper foil then sent
right back to north america to be made
into batteries jb is also scouting
locations to build a billion-dollar
cathode factory that should come online
in 2025. now scaling this facility up
will take time but jb knows that
entrepreneurship is a marathon not a
sprint he's already looking toward a
2030 goal of supporting nearly 10
million electric vehicles per year that
type of long-term thinking has risks if
ev adoption slows this facility could
sit idle but if current projections hold
redwood will be in the perfect position
north america isn't the only market that
jb is considering though europe has many
of the same supply chain issues when it
comes to battery manufacturing so he's
planning on setting up a factory over
there by 2023 the ultimate goal here is
zero waste pull materials out of old
batteries and use those materials to
create new batteries it's a remarkably
simple model but the engineering effort
here is enormous jb is pouring hundreds
of millions of dollars into his research
and development efforts and they are
already starting to see some results
over 95 percent of the contents of a
dead battery can now be successfully
salvaged the only problem here is that
there actually might not be enough old
batteries to recycle into new materials
jb has to scale redwood at roughly the
same rate as the overall electric
vehicle industry but demand for new
batteries is much higher than the supply
of used ones so jb and his team are now
working on recycling batteries from
phones cameras and other consumer
devices basically anything with a
lithium ion battery in it is fair game
in jb's book it's something like 90
percent of the batteries that get sold
to consumers put in small devices end up
not recycled redwood now has drop off
points with best buy to collect these
old batteries and the plan seems to be
working especially for cobalt consumer
electronics have so much cobalt that
redwood might never need to worry about
mining it ever again
sort of amazing but only a few hundred
iphones you know can provide enough
cobalt to make a new tesla battery pack
jb's entire plan for redwood revolves
around reducing the environmental
footprint of the battery supply chain
manufacturing a new battery pack for an
electric vehicle using only new
materials creates over five tons of
carbon emissions but redwood has already
lowered that to just over 3 tons per
battery pack and has no plans to stop
there jb envisions a future where no
mining needs to occur to make batteries
once the recycling ecosystem kicks into
high gear old batteries will provide
everything needed to make new ones it is
worth pointing out here that when a
battery wears down the only thing that's
actually destroyed inside the battery
are the chemical connections between the
different metals all of the components
are still inside of the cell and with
the right technology they can be
repurposed into new batteries redwood's
battery components won't just be better
for the environment though they could
also be cheaper back in 2010 the price
of cathodes anodes and other cell
materials made up only 30 of the cost of
battery packs the materials weren't the
most expensive part of the batteries the
manufacturing process was but engineers
have since driven down production costs
so materials now account for nearly 60
of the price of the battery jb has
experience taking something expensive
and figuring out how to reduce its cost
without sacrificing quality every dollar
that redwood can save on battery
components translates directly into 60
cents of savings that's a big deal and
will be really important for making
electric vehicles competitive with
traditional gas-powered cars
the story of jb stravel is so important
because it demonstrates the power of
long-term thinking our world is changing
extremely rapidly and certain
technologies are compounding
exponentially things might seem slow at
first but after a few decades of
compounding growth suddenly everything
is different being able to track these
trends into the future and build a
business that addresses an issue that is
just on the horizon is an incredibly
powerful skill and one that every
founder should pay attention to if you
like this video don't forget to go enter
your email at johncoogan.com and please
check out this recommended video the
youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it